اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا سنبدا النشره اخبار
ايلين ماسك اليوميه واللي عنوانها اليوم
مطالبات بالهجوم فائلون ماسك فاجا متابعيه
ومستخدمين تويتر بتغريده بيطلب فيها من
الناس انه
الوحده الاولى الواحد كان بيفكر انه هذا
بحث عن الجدل مثلا او انها رساله مبطنه
معناها انه مش فارق معه الحرب اللي شغاله
ضده لكن التركيز شوي بيكشف الموضوع
محدد هو موجهها لمين وكاتب في اول تغريده
انها نداء وحاطط الايموجيز اللي شايفينهم
امامكم وطبعا قصده مفهوم الحسابات الوهميه
المعروفات بالواتس واللي هي اصلا كانت سبب
اساسي في تعطيل صفقه مع تويتر لفتره واللي
بيوعد هو بانه راح يتخلص منها على تويتر
او على الاقل راح يقللها بنسبه كبيره
اذا ماسك طلب من الواتس فيه تغريده انهم
يهاجموه وبعدين اتضح السبب فيبدوا ان
الموضوع كان مجرد اختبار من ماسك لا جهود
تويتر حتى الان في التصدي للحسابات
الوهميه اللي عم نحكي عنها لانه بعدها
بربع ساعه غرد من جديد وقال حلو كثير
الواتس حتى الان مش قادره تطلع للاعلى في
الردود على تغريدتي وقصده تغريدته وما
زالت الاولى والموضوع يعني انجاز يقصد في
التحكم بالتغريدات اللي صادره عن حسابات
وهميه وانها ما تكون منتشره بشكل واسع
السؤال الان هل يا ترى هاي هي المفاجاه
لمسك من امبارح وقعد فيها الحسابات
الوهميه ولا لسه في شيء ثاني لانه كان غرد
امبارح وقال انه مخبي مفاجاه للواتس اليوم
والى جانب المواجهه مع الباص في خبرين عن
مواجهات اخرى لمسك متصدر العناوين اولهم
واجهتهم مع دكتور انفني فوتشي كبير اطباء
البيت الابيض واللي كان من علامات مرحله
كرونه وبستعد للتقاعد نهايه هذا الشهر
ماسك نشا تغريده بيطالب فيها بمحاكمته
والموضوع عمل جدل وانقسام واسع في كثار
ومنهم كثير جمهوريين معه وبيدعموا
مطالباته مطالبات ماسك وكثر منهم
اكثر منهم بيكونوا ديموقراطين كمان ومن
علم العلم بهجموا وبيلتقدوا لتفكير فقط
ماسك وبعد ما اشترك تويتر وقف العمل
بالسياسات اللي كانت متبعه فيها او في ما
يخص تحديدا المعلومات المغلوطه عنه اما
المواجهه الثانيه اللي عم نحكي عنها لمصف
الساعات الماضيه فكانت مش مباشره لكنها
مفاجئه ففي مجموعه تسريبات الجديده اللي
عم تنشر عن اداره تويتر السابقه وطورتها
في امور كثيره انتشرت امبارح نسخه جديده
من الملفات وهذا الجزء بيحكي عن تورط جهات
واشخاص في الضغط على تويتر لاحظره ترامب
والمفاجاه كانت في الناس اللي قيل انها
متواصلوا مع تويتر وضغطوا عليها على راسهم
كانت السيده الاولى السابقه اوباما
والملفات كشفت كمان كيف تويتر غيرت
سياساتها
متعمده لتخليها بتسمح لها انها تحضر ترامب
شكلها كامل